we've said all along aaron rodgers has
every right
to be upset with the packers for how
they handle this every right
even though i still don't buy the whole
people person's pay-per-people routine
from aaron rodgers and i'm surprised
alex smith does he knows how the
business is
he knows how it goes but aaron rodgers
believed that he had
transcended the usual treatment that the
guy at the bottom of the roster gets
that's right
after what he's done for the team how
he's professed repeatedly that he wants
to stay
and then they do this to him without the
courtesy of a phone call
and clearly set in motion a plan to
supplant him with jordan lava a plan
into which he threw a wrench by being
the league mvp and i suspect they
they hoped that that would be the
reaction the problem is now they can't
trade him how can you trade the reigning
mvp
and it's got to play out for one more
year but i agree with a lot of what alex
smith said
and he's in a position to know what the
feeling would be and he got the phone
call
that's the key right that that's the key
you know that is the key
honestly i i think it you know really is
is a little extra powerful when a guy
like alex smith kind of says what he
says though because he's not the kind of
guy to make a real
blanket headline statement like that
so that shows you how it jumps out to
him
one i mean i think he's saying it right
i mean yeah i i
i get what you're saying mike the whole
people thing all that i i think we know
the analogy he was trying to make even
though it was a little weird or awkward
or all that
but that's not i don't know the analogy
he was trying to make i think he's just
pandering to the fans
well maybe i think either way he's
trying to tell you that he feels
personally disrespected that he was one
of the
people the very important people if not
the
most important person and he felt like
how do you do this to me
you know don't even tell me no idea
and you know alex smith there he is he
knows he goes
well i know i'm not the player aaron
rodgers is and my organization even told
me
so that he's looking at that going crazy
let alone i think most quarterbacks
around football also look at it and go
it's inexcusable and i say that because
i think most quarterbacks in football
look at aaron rodgers
and think he's a lot better than maybe
the public even thinks that he is
that they look at him like holy cow how
do you do that to that guy the guy
that's like
unbelievable unstoppable and all that
and that's where
i think alex smith's you know statement
has has some power behind it
i have a thought that i want to run by
you because alex smith
said he was told multiple times what the
chiefs plan to do there were no
surprises it was
absolutely laid out for me right and i
think
that all helps when it's communicated it
does make a difference how you treat
people
here's my question yeah because the
chiefs
clearly trusted alex smith
to keep his mouth shut about what they
were planning to do
something that no one knew they were
planning to do
and there was a small handful of coaches
out there
that wanted patrick mahomes including
the coach whose team picked at number 11
the new orleans saints
and lo and behold the chiefs cut the
line in front of sean payton right
if someone had known what the chiefs
were thinking about doing
everything potentially changes and oh
hey look at this there's no one to
supplant me
i say all that because could the
explanation
be as simple as this the packers didn't
trust aaron rodgers with that knowledge
could he because he'd sabotage maybe
he'd make sure someone knew the packers
want jordan love to try to keep them
from getting jordan love yeah i think
that that that may be
and if if mark murphy brian guticus were
forced to tell the truth
why didn't you do it are you just
completely inconsiderate are you dumb
are you stupid do you just have no
respect for aaron rodgers or
were you afraid aaron rodgers was going
to hatch a plan and implement that plan
to make sure someone else knew about it
so they'd get jordan love instead
yeah i listen it's an interesting
thought i don't think it's like a crazy
thought by any stretch of the
imagination too maybe they're that that
that is you know part of what their
strategic you know approach was to this
usually with a decision like that right
you and i both
know it's like few people in the
organization go
listen from all accounts we it doesn't
sound like matt lafleur had any idea
they were going to draft jordan love
that that he didn't know so you're down
to we're talking about with these type
of decisions two or three people within
an organization that know
actually what's going to be done you
know so you can tell the quarterback
and figure out if it does get out
publicly
who it came from that would be an easy
find so that would be the risk you're
playing as a player
to do that type of thing there's no
doubt and listen
what are they gonna do what are they
gonna do cut him i know you're right
it's it's
not gonna cut him aaron aaron did you
aaron did you tell anyone i didn't tell
anyone
i didn't tell anyone yeah what are they
gonna do what are they gonna do no
they're not gonna do anything other than
you know it's gonna ruin their
relationship i would guess right
they're gonna look at him like what the
hell already
i know same place i know different paths
but also within that why i don't think
the player would do that really either
is they're going to tell people those
people are going to tell people to then
where aaron rodgers going to look like a
real jerk because it's going to get out
and now it's going to be like
whoa aaron rodgers tried to sabotage the
first round pick and all those type of
things
that's where i would have a hard time
believing the player would would do that
i guess
not not if not if the player is smart
right does it discreetly
right and has a plan you can do it in a
way where there's no fingerprints
represented by david dunn he can get the
word out through athletes first
he you can get the word out that there
but now it makes a little awkward
because athletes first also represents
jordan love but that's beside the point
i'm just wondering when i look at what
alex smith had to say
and the idea that the chiefs did trust
him with the most
sensitive of information that shows
that gesture alone shows how much
respect they have for him when you are
someone who is trusted with highly
sensitive information
that there there is in that gesture a
message
that you are someone who is important
you are someone who is part of
the inner circle you are someone who is
being trusted
and and you you become less likely to
violate that trust when you understand
you're being entrusted with such
important information that's right
and they didn't trust aaron rodgers with
that information which makes it even
more of a slap in the face it's not just
hey we didn't tell aaron rodgers what
was coming
at a deeper level we didn't trust you
to have that information and that's
another reason why he may be upset
and that's why he's saying it's about
the people and
the front office of football teams will
from time to time
if not all the time treat players like
commodities sure
and there's and there's a line to that
and there are certain players who
shouldn't be treated like commodities
and aaron rodgers should not be treated
like a commodity and i think that that's
really his message he was treated
like a commodity by the front office and
they wouldn't even trust him with the
knowledge
that they were going to make this move
or even give him the courtesy of the
heads up
and explain to him why they were doing
what they were doing yeah
i mean listen mike i i don't think you
know maybe you're onto something maybe
that is part of it
i mean do you know this or you just
theorize like a theory here okay
all right all right this is because this
is all this is all happening
as we speak well this is one of the
benefits of not preparing
you just sit down and you let it flow
and as i look at those words yeah
i i it just the light bulb went off they
trusted alex smith
in kansas city they didn't trust aaron
rodgers in greenbelt yeah
i'm not going to argue there i don't
know that i think that's still
speculative you you know who's going to
who's going to admit to it but wait wait
you're right no one is
going to admit to it let's call the
packers now shannon sharp
no one's going to i know but it's also i
get it
trust aaron rodgers it's all implied by
the facts it's circumstantial evidence i
know it is what they actually believe
right i i get that i know we're never
going to know it's a it would be a good
excuse for them to say that to
if it's you know a good you know the
situation they're in as a debacle
that's a nice thing for them to be able
to say well we didn't really trust him
oh okay
all right and listen do you think that
would make it better uh
i don't think it would make it much
better no the fact that what and it's
not gonna make it much worse
no it's definitely not gonna make it any
better no it's not gonna make it much
better and here listen i'll say this too
like again you said it
players are taught or commodities in the
nfl
you don't they don't have to tell aaron
rodgers what they're doing in the draft
and those type of things
they don't i don't know i want i don't
know did tom brady get a call that the
patriots are going to draft jimmy
garoppolo
and all that i don't know but see here's
the difference though
new england like that's always the
business that's the way
they go it's team team team and billet
belichick's king king
king and that's not the way it's set up
in green bay we know that it's a little
different that way
where the quarterback is part of the you
know the king
the hierarchy there in green bay has
been for a while that's been part of it
so that's where i also think it's a
little different maybe than other
organizations as well because they put
so much weight
into one guy all the time that's where i
think he gets into the people the
foundation and all those things whether
they
lied to them didn't trust them didn't
tell them and either way
they're all wrong to do to the guy who
we know has carried your organization
for the past you know 11 or 12 years
well and and i think we're touching on a
deeper issue in an organization without
yes an owner that's it aaron rodgers
is the highest paid and most important
employee of the corporation
and i think it's always awkward
when yeah the people who are making the
decisions
about the most important and highest
paid
in a corporation are making less
and far less important than
the person about whom the decisions are
being made yeah
does that make any sense at all there's
no way mark murphy's making more than
aaron rodgers
there's no way brian guticus is even
within
30 million of what aaron rodgers is
making
yet these are the guys who are making
the decisions about one of the great
football players of all time
there's something awkward in all of that
when you don't have an
owner who clearly becomes the most
important and highest paid
person right in any football
organization right it's different than
new england right you got mr craft and
then you got
bill where who knows what he's making we
know he's the highest
but he's not making no he's not making
it great or thirty or four should but
the combination of those two
set a hierarchy of going like hey it's
craft and then it's belichick just right
under him and then here's the
quarterback and the players and all of
that
and i think that's the hierarchy that
you know we we look at to be
the most successful to make the most
sense you know
seems to be the one that avoids
situations like this maybe the most
that's where it gets back to the owner
thing you bring up so much
that you know i think there's real
weight behind that and and some of these
points
and you can't help but wonder when you
start delving into these dynamics
is there an unspoken
and possibly a subconscious resentment
of aaron rodgers and have they had
enough
yeah and he makes these little comments
from time to time and he's always doing
these passive aggressive things and
wouldn't we all be better off long term
if we just had another quarterback
things that may not even have to be
spoken out loud it just becomes
understood
between murphy and gouda kunst man this
is just a
pain in the ass how much is our life
going to change if we have to we at some
point we got to get a new quarterback
anyway
why don't we just go ahead and do it
again it's it's
it's fascinating it's almost
shakespearean when you consider all the
personalities and forces at play here
and
hey if they were trying
if their goal was to completely
obliterate
the relationship with aaron rodgers
bravo you did it now if you weren't
trying shame on you
but if you were trying to do it it's as
impressive a feat
of a destruction of a relationship
between a football
front office and a player as i've ever
seen you're right it is it's up there
with any i can remember certainly with
this caliber a caliber of player
you know i don't know you you'd maybe
remember maybe you remember some back in
the old days but i can't remember like
a star i wasn't trying to be funny there
i was being serious
okay like maybe in the 70s or something
i was not trying to be funny
i was being told back in the old days
well the only thing before electricity
like back before i was capable of
knowing and remembering everything about
football in the media that's all i was
talking about okay don't get all
sensitive on me all right that's all i
was talking about
but yeah i'm with you that's weird there
also
i agree with you that hey aaron rodgers
as much as i love him and you know i'm
biased and i think he's the man
i i certainly can see how he could wear
on people in an organization i'm not
that blind to it or blinded by his
greatness and all that
yeah he's a people he wears on people
who aren't in the organization he's a
pain in the butt
you know he is he's obviously kind of an
eccentric thinker and
very deep that way and hey maybe a
little bit sensitive about what's said
to him
and yeah you're right there's been a lot
of things there uh that
that have been said that are cryptic
like that they're probably like oh
manny's a handful man the mccarthy thing
man lefleur we hire them and now we got
to talk about the audibles and do all
that
oh it's uh you know i could see them
being like man every year it's something
i i do get that
but that's the price of like greatness
most of the time like really
what great players weren't a pain in the
butt michael jordan was a pain in the
butt for the bulls in the end of the 90s
a lot of these great players were
throughout their history
kind of what makes them great in a lot
of ways and then of course like we talk
about they get a little power from the
organization
and they can kind of funnel out of
control sometimes too
and and this example is an extreme one
but i thought of antonio brown in
pittsburgh because they tolerated him
until they got to the point where they
thought
it's he's getting close to the end of
his
god-given physical ability to the point
where it's worth tolerating and i think
that's what happened with the packers
if aaron rodgers is 27
yeah dominance yeah yeah
then you deal with it right but the
train is getting close
to the station anyway and chris you you
said it yourself you saw some slippage
in 2019 yeah they went 13-3
and made it to the nfc championship and
and and look bill belichick
what's he best known for when it comes
to
separating from players sure doing it a
year early
instead of a year too late and
he look the way it all happened it
convinced aaron rodgers they had a plan
and the plan consisted of throwing him
overboard after the 2020 season he
believed that
and still believes that and believes the
only thing that saved him was his mvp
season right which means that they're
now waiting
they're going to throw him overboard
after 2021 if he doesn't have another
mvp season and he's trying to
short-circuit that process that's it
it's that
simple yep that's the conclusion he's
reached
and he's the one who's in a far better
position to reach that conclusion than
anyone on the outside yeah that that
that's exactly right i mean
yeah you know and a lot even us on the
outside
you you could certainly make sense of
the conclusion he might have made out of
this whole thing but
you know again i think that's where it
really comes back to you you laid it out
perfectly
but yet this guy wasn't yes i saw that
slippage but it still was
we're talking slippage from being
absolutely the man at number one
to now whoa mahomes is you know
he's passed you by and russell wilson's
getting a little like
still we're talking slippage of he went
to the top three or the top five right
it's that way too
and that's where the fine line of this
dance has you know gotten the green bay
packers in trouble with rogers a little
bit too here
yeah look i think we're on the same page
and i think that we've we've handled the
topic as well as we possibly can not
that we've done it
incredibly well just as well as we
individually based on our own abilities
can do it hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports